bring your gasoline and count to seven
because we have the scariest film to
come out on Netflix since a Christmas
Prince Netflix is the haunting of Hell
House is truly a horrific tale that
masterfully blends family drama with
horror while weaving a complex mythology
around Hill House and its many ghostly
entities now because this show is so
massive this video is split into two
parts half one explaining the ghosts and
half two explaining the ending so if you
want to skip the first portion and get
right to the ending I've left a link in
the description now let's get into the
fun stuff the haunting of Hill House is
filled with dozens of ghosts some we see
and actually play a role in the story
others we don't see but are mentioned
like the unblinking lady the boy from
episode one believes is his grandmother
or car horn Karl who Steve investigates
in that episode as well
finally there are mystery ghosts who
show up hidden in the frame like here
here or here we don't know anything
about them and they have no impact on
the story so for the purposes of this
segment we're gonna focus on those
ghosts that we see and affect the
storyline first is the bent neck lady or
as we find out in episode 5 Nelly drawn
back to the home after being haunted by
her and at the suggestion of her
therapist to confront her demons Nelly
ventures back to Hill House only to be
seduced by its charm ultimately ending
in her hanging and when she does so we
realized it was her all along the ghost
of the bent neck lady was her haunting
her as a child and through her adult
life how that's possible I'll discuss in
the ending segment the bent neck lady or
dead Nelly acts as a benevolent ghost
helping the kids out from their dreams
in the Red Room warning them away from
Hill House and even getting pissed off
when they fight with each other
her ghost is arguably the most important
because Nellie's death is what brings
all the kids together forcing them to
confront their traumas and move on with
their lives if it weren't for Nelly the
bent neck lady Luke would still be an
addict
Steve would still be estranged from his
wife Theo would continue to distance
herself from others and Shirley would
still live with the guilt of her affair
not so benevolent is Olivia the matron
Ark of the family after killing herself
alundra the spell of poppy Hill who
we'll get to in a minute she spends her
time trying to get the children back to
Hill House she wants to be with them
forever or as she calls it awake which
is just Hill House speak for dead in
fact in episode 9 she says she wishes
she could just freeze them keep them
young forever this is especially evident
in episode 10 when Luke overdoses and is
confronted with his mother at the tea
party he can sit and stay with her
forever but it's young Nelly who tells
him don't go before older Nelly brings
him out of his dream Olivia tells Hugh
at the end she wants to keep them there
to protect them these kids aren't ready
for the world out there the pain the
sorrow and she's partly right look at
how they all turned out after her death
at least in Hill House nothing bad will
touch them but he reminds her nothing
good will either Olivia also appears as
a coping mechanism for Hugh helping him
with what to say to his children at
Nellie's funeral as Steve says in
episode 1 ghosts can take many forms but
most times they are a wish Hugh wants to
see his wife so he imagines her Luke
later calls him out on it
reminding him what he said when he was a
child big boys know the difference
between what is real and imaginary our
third ghost delves into the history of
Hill House with poppy Hill the wife of
William Hill the bowler hat man and
sister-in-law to Hazel Hill the old lady
Clara looked after on her deathbed poppy
met William at the mental asylum where
they were both patients when they got
out they married and moved to Hill House
hazel and poppy had a tumultuous
relationship
hazel calling her a liar - Olivia when
poppy tries to get her to kill her
children poppy had three children with
William all three of which is heavily
implied she killed in her conversation
with Olivia she recounts how all of them
died notably her son who lost feeling in
his legs and died cold in her arms we
even get a glimpse of him in episode 6
he's the wheelchair boy Olivia sees in
her dream during the storm
poppy went mad believing she can save
her kids from the hardships of the world
by killing them or as she refers to it
as awakening them she then tries to get
Olivia to do the same with her children
and this mental episode could have been
partly brought upon by her
husband's infidelity William Hill aka
the tall man with the cane was Poppy's
husband we learned in Episode seven that
he walled himself in Hill House in an
attempt to escape from the demons fear
and guilt the fear and guilt coming from
his affair with a housemaid Horace
Dudley tells Hugh that he was born in
Hill House and his mother worked there
he could often hear his mother giggling
to herself outside their cottage as if
talking to someone leading me to believe
that horse is the illegitimate son of
William Hill and poppy likely knew about
her husband's love for women in Episode
nine she says to Olivia in episode 10
trish tells Theo that she once knew a
man who had two sisters fear and guilt
every day they turned him a little more
mad he walled himself in to get away
from them his fear and guilt made him
feel small but when he awoke he was tall
that was his dream that is the story of
William Hill we then have Abigail the
daughter of Horace and Clara Dudley we
first see her as Luke's imaginary friend
but at this point it's reasonable to
believe she is real it's only when
Olivia arrives back and has the poisoned
tea party that Abigail dies and joins
the countless other ghosts in Hill House
Horace and Clara seeing their daughter's
ghost make a deal with Hugh that they'll
keep his secret to save his children's
memory of Olivia as long as he doesn't
burn down Hill House this deal made out
of the love for their child who they can
now visit anytime they want
in the final episode Horace brings a
dying Clara to Hell House so she too can
be with Abigail forever we then have who
I like to call the Scotch drinking man
Ryan Quayle who is first seen in episode
2 and not again until episode 6 seeing
as this show defines a ghost broadly for
example they can be a memory daydream
grief or guilt among other things
Ryan is Shirley's guilty ghost she had a
one-night stand with him while out the
embalming convention very romantic and
she never told her husband about it he
continually haunts her as a reminder of
her guilt we also have Luke who for a
brief moment appears as a ghost to Nelly
his ghostly appearance is because he
actually dies for a brief moment before
being resuscitated we then have a cadre
of minor ghosts who appear as daydreams
hallucinate
fears and wishes there's mr. smiley the
manifestation of young Kelsie's
molesting foster father who took the
form of the floorboards witch Theo saw
the clock repairman whose sole purpose
in the plot is to prove to Steve that he
was seeing ghosts all the time but he
just didn't realize it we then have lead
Joey and Shirley who all turned into
manifestations of fears for Steven Luke
and Shirley herself the ghosts in
haunting of Hill House provide the
impetus for change in our characters
they are what make our characters
confront their traumas and it's the
ending of Hill House that really
solidifies this message only by
confronting our troubles can we no
longer be haunted by the past and strive
to live better lives as Nellie's
therapist says in Episode five her real
problem is not her siblings it's not
confronting the pain of her past the
events of Hill House created traumas for
our characters each one coping with them
in different ways from Luke's addiction
Theo's meaningless sex and inability to
open up Nellie's depression Shirley the
control freak or Steve's unwillingness
to see the truth their ways of coping
like Luke's drugs for example don't get
at the core of what caused these traumas
in the first place they are merely
band-aids
it's only when each character is
confronted by their worst fear in the
Red Room that they must face it head-on
there is no place to hide here Steve
must confront his belief that if he had
a child it'll turn out diseased like his
mother Shirley must confront her
infidelity Luke his addiction which he
overcomes by choosing not to die and
Theo her inability to open up and let
others love her bottling up our trauma
keeping secrets only makes things worse
and those things can haunt us perhaps
the greatest encapsulation of this is
when Shirley confronts her dead body in
episode 10 the funeral manager tells her
on the outside she is fixed and pretty
but on the inside she is a horror our
greatest Horrors are not what's on the
outside they are buried within us when
Nellie releases them all from their
dreams they each have a chance to
apologize to her but she tells them she
knows they all love each other
unconditionally and that love is all
that matters
the rest is confetti interesting is her
speech about time stating that she used
to think it was linear but it's more
like rain moments falling around
this explains how she as a younger girl
saw herself as the bent neck lady the
Red Room according to Nelly is like the
stomach of the house putting on faces so
it can slowly digest them Hugh even
tells Steve that the house has called
the Mack because they're like an
unfinished meal a stomach breaks down
into pieces what we put into it
just like how the Red Room breaks down
the crane family when Hugh and Steven
drive to Hill House Hugh makes reference
to the clock repairman in the overalls
with the handlebar mustache he tells
Stephen about witness marks scars found
on antique clocks which show the repairs
that have been done to them Hill House
is much like an antique clock and the
characters are the witness marks
whatever that life is bear witness the
crane family even came there to repair
the house remember that Hugh and Olivia
are house flippers and just like an
antique clock there is no record of
their previous repairs hence why Olivia
must recreate floor plans and why we
know so little about the previous
tenants we the viewer will see the
damage through the other characters who
bear witness to these ghostly beings as
I said before it's only by confronting
their traumas their hearts of darkness
do the characters leave Hill House
healed
Stephen reconciles with his father and
Leigh we even get a short glimpse of Lea
pregnant at the end with Luke
celebrating his recovery
Shirley comes clean about her infidelity
to her husband and Theo moves out
throwing away her gloves and apparently
in a relationship with Trish who she had
constantly pushed away but the house
gives and takes and the price for this
was Hugh at the end of the episode we
see that Hugh has died and he says a
final farewell to Stephen before joining
Olivia and Nellie I believe that when he
said goodbye to his children as they
fled he was already dead and they were
seeing him as a ghost that his death was
a deal he made with Olivia to let his
children go free when Hugh tells Liv to
let them go she breaks down telling them
that she'll be alone again a few moments
later he tells her that he'll make a
promise that will last forever but we as
the viewer never get to hear what that
promise is he tells her let me fix it
and sacrifices himself to be with Olivia
in exchange for letting the children go
take a look at Olivia's face looking
back at Stephen when Hugh goes to join
them in the Red Room it's not one of
happiness it's one of a woman who just
let her children go
knowing it will be longer before they're
finally reunited last but not least is
Stephens monologue about love and fear
how they both involve the relinquishment
of logic this willing relinquishment of
reasonable patterns we either give into
it or fight it there's no meeting
halfway without it we cannot continue to
live sanely under conditions of absolute
reality and that's what our characters
have tried to do ever since they left
Hill House meet in that halfway and it's
only when they give in to love to be
honest with one another that they can
all live sanely in the absolute reality
never to be haunted again the haunting
of Hill House is an emotional tale one
that shows us our greatest fears lay in
our innermost horrors our traumas the
pain to take on those traumas is
sometimes too much and we cope with
drugs sex or the easy way out it's only
when we confront our demons that they
can no longer exist and it's through
that confrontation that we become
stronger I hope you enjoyed this video
be sure to LIKE and subscribe if not you
can find me in the Red Room I also have
a Twitter account where you can get
updates on my videos and check out my
other breakdowns on this channel until
next time